ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu monsieur le ministre le
1er janvier 2023 la zone A faible
émission du Grand Lyon est entre en
vigueur pour les voitures des
particuliers après une période
pédagogique de quatre mois la cause
affichée on peut le dire est
indiscutable cependant combattre les
particules fines ne peut se faire au
détriment des plus modestes des
travailleurs qui se lèvent tôt qui sont
eux les grands oubliés de cette
politique écologique punitive car les
classes populaires ne polluent pas
volontairement elle ne peuvent pas faire
autrement on ne pollue pas
volontairement quand on habite en
banlieue on ne pollue pas volontairement
quand la métropole de Lyon ajoute
l'extension des lignes de métro quelle
hypocrisie de la part des dirigeants
verts de vouloir sanctionner les plus
modestes qui ne peuvent pas s'acheter
une voiture neuve ou une voiture
électrique au risque de les reléguer
dans les banlieues en leur interdisant
ainsi l'entrée dans les grandes villes y
compris pour aller travailler face à la
mobilisation d'une grande partie de la
population et des élus locaux la
métropole de Lyon a annoncé ralentir la
cadence par rapport au calendrier
initial mais ce n'est vous en
conviendrez que reporter le problème que
comptez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour mettre fin à la sourde colère qui
gronde face à cette écologie punitive
qui creuse des inégalités sociales entre
les centres urbains et les habitants des
quartiers populaires ainsi que des
centaines de villes moyennes comme Dreux
pour Paris ou Villefranche-sur-Saône
pour Lyon il ne faut pas que ces aid et
feux deviennent un outil de ségrégation
et d'assignation à résidence je vous
remercie